you know, in the Donetsk and Lugansk People's Republics of the Zaporizhia and Kherson regions, referendums were held, their results are summed up, the people have made their choice, they made an unambiguous choice. constitutional laws on the adoption and formation in Russia of four new regions of four new subjects of the Russian Federation because this is the Will of millions of people Vladimir Vladimirovich Putin we call on the Kyiv regime to immediately cease fire all hostilities that war that he unleashed back in 2014 and return to the negotiating table we we are ready for this, it has been said more than once, but we will not discuss the choice of the peoples Donetsk Lugansk Zaporozhye Kherson we will not discuss it is done Russia will not betray him [applause] And today's Kyiv authorities should treat this free
we will protect our Earth with all the
forces and means we have and
will do everything to ensure the safe
life of our people in this great
liberation mission of our people
our compatriots our brothers and
sisters in Ukraine  native part of our
united people With their own eyes they saw
that the ruling circles of the so-called
West are preparing for all mankind such a
complete denial of man non-refutation of
faith and traditional values ​​under the
pressure of Freedom acquires the features of a
religion on the contrary of outright satanism of the
Soviet Union there is no return of the past
Yes, and Russia today is no longer needed
we do not strive for this, but there is nothing
stronger than the determination of millions of people
who, according to their culture, faith, tradition,
language,
consider themselves part of Russia
Whose ancestors lived in the United State for centuries,
there is nothing stronger than the
determination of these people to return to their
true, their true historical  The Russian
Fatherland in the intention to preserve its
unlimited power is the
real reasons for the hybrid war
that the collective West is waging against
Russia. They don’t want us to be free, they want to
see us as colonies. Although
they want to see us as an unfree society and robbery as a
crowd of soulless slaves, a direct threat to them.
our thought and philosophy are
therefore encroaching on our philosophers
our culture is a danger to them of
art therefore they are trying to
prohibit our development prosperity is also a
threat to them competition they do not
need Russia at all we need it